[Music]
hey what's up i'm kbhd here and this
oppo find n might actually be the best
folding phone on planet earth right now
at least in terms of form factor so as
far as foldables go samsung's galaxy z
fold 3 is the gold standard right huge
outside screen goes right up to the
edges then the large unfolding inside
screen with the hidden selfie camera
flagship specs and cameras and build
quality so the number one question is if
you could change anything about the fold
what would you change
and as someone who's used the fold the
most common answer that i've heard is
if it was just not quite as tall if we
could just make it smaller like if
you've ever looked at the fold while
it's closed it's got that super tall
unconventional aspect ratio and if you
wanted to make it more usable you'd
shrink it down right
enter oppo find n now i'm just going to
preface this video by saying most people
watching this video here on youtube will
never see
this phone because it's a china only
phone and youtube is not available
officially in china so this impressions
video is more of my evaluation of the
hardware and the idea of a smaller
folding phone not whether you should buy
one or not although it does technically
undercut the fold so it turns out there
are a lot of benefits that come from
shrinking down the folds form factor and
low-key this might make it a contender
for best small phone of the year so the
outside screen is only five and a half
inches diagonally now the rest of the
phone is of course thicker so we'll get
to that in a second but shrinking the
whole thing down like this makes it much
more usable from corner to corner as a
normal phone so it's got a normal 2x1
aspect ratio on the outside and it
happens to be a really nice bright
nearly 1080p screen so it's sitting at
over 400 ppi pixel density but the point
is it's way more usable and way more
pocketable it's literally about the same
size as an iphone 13 mini now of course
it is thicker than the iphone but that's
because you open it up the same way as
the fold with this nice firm smooth
hinge to reveal a much larger inside
screen so oppo calls this the serene
display for some reason i don't know why
everything has to have a name but it's a
7.1 inch diagonal 1920x1729
120 hertz ltpo folding display so on
paper this is only slightly smaller than
the z-fold 3's 7.4 inch diagonal but it
does feel a meaningfully smaller and
with that 8.4 by 9 aspect ratio it's
it's nearly squared up it feels kind of
like a little notebook size so it's nice
it's a little less massive and
intimidating you might not be using it
all the time as a productivity
multitasking device but it's still a
convenient huge screen for media writing
things down single apps at a time and it
also feels way more likely to be
switched back and forth between portrait
and landscape super easily also gotta
love the 120hz ltpotech which can ramp
down the refresh rate when there's not
as much happening to save that battery
this phone has the ultra thin glass over
the crease that the galaxy fold has and
it also does have a protective layer
over that you can actually feel the
cutout over the selfie camera
probably shouldn't remove that
protective layer but the point is this
phone has all the same fundamentals that
the z-fold three has i keep referring to
the fold three because that's the
high-end folding phone that we're mostly
all here familiar with but this really
does feel like oppo's version oppo's own
modification of that idea so the hinge
is really high quality it's firm and
smooth which inspires confidence holding
it it can stop at any number of
positions up to 120 degrees open and sit
on a table not as much software to take
advantage of it but oppo has built in a
couple things you can use the hinge as a
tripod to prop up the selfie camera and
take photos like that you can try to
watch some videos but oppo hasn't really
optimized any of their apps or even
worked with the google apps to move it
up to the top half of the display so it
doesn't look great but the software does
have really good continuity between open
and closed states so if you're reading
something while it's closed and then you
open it of course it just appears and
fills that full screen now if you're
doing something with the screen open and
then close it you know sometimes that
just means you're done you just close
the phone you're done using it but
sometimes you actually want to pick up
where you left off on the smaller
display in which case you close it and
then just swipe up and the screen turns
on and lights back up exactly what you
were using on the cover screen they've
also got the fingerprint reader on the
power button they've got a dual speaker
setup for dolby atmos sound they've also
dropped in the high end specs snapdragon
triple eight up to 512 gigs of storage
and eight or 12 gigs of ram and they've
got the triple cameras on the back the
50 megapixel main camera a 14 millimeter
ultra wide and a telephoto and oppo's
had some pretty great cameras on their
phone for the past couple of years this
one's rounded camera bump reminds me a
bit of the find x3 pro which i really
liked you know it is wild though so they
did so much of the same stuff that
samsung did the ultra thin glass the
great hinge the triple cameras all that
stuff
and it's a smaller phone
but
they've somehow managed to fit a larger
battery in this phone than the fold now
it's still split between two batteries
actually it's one in each side so
combining the one on the right with the
one on the left for that balance it's a
4500 milliamp hour battery total which
is larger than the fold 3's 4 400
milliamp hours now again this isn't a
full review i haven't been using it long
enough to know if that actually
translates to really great battery life
but
the math checks out smaller screens
bigger battery seems pretty great and
that also ties sort of hand in hand with
the one con the one downside that i
really know about a phone like this
which is the outside screen is just 60
hertz that would have been nice i mean
it would have cost more battery but it
would have been nice to match the inside
and outside screens at 120 hertz samsung
did have the 60 on the outside and the
120 on the inside on the fold 2 before
they matched them on the fold 3. but
either way this is fascinating it
doesn't necessarily have to move things
forward technologically speaking i still
think the level of like crease
visibility for example and feel ability
is about the same as samsung and huawei
which is to say barely visible when
you're actually looking at the content
but it's still pretty visible when
you're really looking for it but you
know they don't even do the selfie
camera underneath the display they still
have a selfie camera cutout in the
corner but don't forget about the
ability to unfold the whole thing and
use the primary cameras and the outside
screen as the viewfinder but this isn't
a copy of the fold either i really feel
like the design is the one thing they
really embraced the most as their own
this two-tone look with the matte finish
on the back the slight slope up to the
camera bump and they also put a bit of
text on the indent in the really nice
hinge it says designed for find look at
this a piece of paper
no gap at all while closed
that's as good as it gets right now
you know what else is as good as it gets
right now our new channel sponsor cash
app so you may already know cash app
lets you invest but we should also know
is they also have a debit card that you
can customize so cash app will laser
print and mail it to you and it also
comes with a bunch of discounts on
places you love called boosts so use
code marquez to sign up and you'll get
15 bucks in your account
just like that it's free money and also
they asked me what charity i wanted to
work with and so for every one of you
who uses that code to sign up for cash
app ten dollars would go to girls who
code that's the charity i chose so
that's a win-win so some other little
tidbits that didn't fit into the rest of
this uh this phone is not
ipx8 certified like samsung's is
but oppo told me and reassures me that
they tested it rigorously and so they're
comfortable saying it'll probably
survive
a splash or going out in the rain or
something like that with regular use and
then also like i mentioned this phone is
china only and they told me that the
price will be under 10 000 un china's
currency i have to sort of translate
that to u.s dollars and that comes out
to about 1500 1550 so it's competitive
maybe even undercutting some of the most
premium flagship folding phones but
that's almost not the point it's just
it's just trying something different and
a little a little a little adjusted from
what we've gotten used to so this whole
folding phone category
has gotten better it's gotten more
options more variations more things to
choose from more ideas out there i'm
curious for those watching are you
on team big fold or littlefold or maybe
neither maybe you're more of a flip
person but i i feel like i do like this
sort of a notebook feel
better than the bigger fold but i'm
curious what you guys think let me know
in the comments that's been it thanks
for watching
catch you guys later
peace
you